oh my god Elizabeth relieve them
remember them okay Mac over teachers
state right you got a tire I mean four
steps Brett ah what's that oh what's
that
okay you go Paul what why did we share
comment like and subscribe if you like
read my smirk on his face you may have
seen the GoPro on a stored video what we
originally wanted to do was cut boob
like balloons in half this is why we
didn't end up doing that this thing
didn't make the cut however we thought
it was too [ __ ] up not to show in some
respect
we saw backyard science video where they
were shooting balloons full of new black
basically a substance that depending on
the screen rate it'd be there a solid or
liquid it's not gonna work okay here's
what I'm going to do here's wrong ado
I'm going to blow into it and as soon as
it like starts going up pinch it so that
it won't come back I'm gonna pinch after
it's poured no no engine now pigeon now
otherwise it's going to go back up okay
okay on pitch tell me sir okay we need
two topic words dude knowing that can't
pen I don't know when to pinch though
okay I'm tension L key pension only
don't we let up on the pitch when I when
you want I blow in I don't know when you
stop looking go dude backyard scientists
how did you do this in 3 2 1 Lego
that's working
we got the last little bit here guard we
need more members closet up man this is
such a why would I glue stuff on my
mouth on everything out I can't do that
okay well I gotta blow into it CPR CPR
wait
tongra did you just say that your dad
got stabbed by a knife this big yes so
it was as thin as this nice though but
it's definitely as long as that how is
he alive so my dad was at training in
Texas got to go to Iraq he snuck out of
the military base when he wasn't
supposed to to go to his favorite place
runneth unfair yes he was his favorite
knife shop cuz he heard that they have a
new new stock a child ran in before
hunting the counter and he was holding
it as yeah he was holding it but he hit
there was a rack of three dozen knives
and it shook and he wanted to stop them
from falling but they all zip up onto
him and they everyone else is hanging
off it was like no problem
one lady just screamed he looks down all
he sees is the handle in his gut blah
and he's like whoa not good his buddies
are like weird Carmichael he comes out
what so they run over to the hospital
and Archer gets the knife pulled out my
dad's first reaction is all thank God it
was a small one there's little installer
size they had
so the doctor said because my dad is
lately heavier it's his weight and fat
that saved him
yeah if it was move it moreover I don't
mother and I'm sure he's been saying it
it's just belly fat that's been saving
his life never excessive ever is it the
scars no no beard the hell out of me
are you all right everybody I think we
had a great system going this video gets
10 million views will have an Oh black
water balloon fight pinch and Chinchin
attention okay that go-gurt wrister
unpinch okay yes that's it good I didn't
make out my finger oh why screaming what
crazy it might be too crazy what if we
somehow put a bunch of corn starch in
the water balloon or in the balloon and
then fill it with water in the fossil
and makes it that way yeah I'm having a
great time instead of mixing it in the
bowl and then trying to get this hell
liquid into the balloons we're going to
be smart we're going to put starch in to
the balloon first and then add the water
if I can go in
a pig got a pension down to face ready
yeah I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
we try that into the blue is what I look
like
okay yeah good so don't work oh we did
have some coin oh yeah I just like oh
that's not going to work we have all
right let's try it right ready we'll do
the same pinching method accordin let me
create a lot of it we create in the air
oh did you not put the tire yourself
into the place you're not wasn't tired
here we go okay
it's not coming out so this was the one
that I was blown into with the actual
blue black is actually not that bad
this one's made a little bit still gonna
pop though this is essentially just
water mark poop like balloon it's
slightly more water than actual black
plate so this is the Oobleck that is a
little bit more solid but because it was
actually a lot more challenging to put
into a balloon than we expected there's
not that much of it so I don't know
what's going to happen because when I
hit it with something it's going to get
rigid so guys create like some tendrils
coming off the back of the sword but
maybe nothing happens so already done
quiz this done
ah
are you doing bread I'm doing alright
alright we can Papa Smurf's I'm pissed
on me a little bit but other than that
it's alright we're filming a storage
site I need a really cool shot to end it
and I want to film something I've never
seen before with the camera nothing on
the school oh the bad guys head in slow
motion